happy monday reject nation uh so last
night i believe marvel they had some abc
special
and uh they put out a i'm sorry oh they
ran
black panther uninterrupted by
commercials yeah so they had
a chadwick boseman tribute at some point
which went up on
marvel entertainment's youtube channel
last night
uh haven't seen this and i wanted to
check it out
and i heard something pretty special and
before we go into that though a couple
of things one
i wanted to give you guys a list of
recommendations of where you can watch
some chadwick bozeman movies you could
watch get on up
on hbo max the five bloods on netflix
black panther on disney plus
42 and marshall i couldn't find it
anywhere on streaming if you guys are
able to find
a spectrum please leave it in the
comments but the only place i could find
where you could rent it
or on youtube and amazon prime so these
are like you know
some of his biggest work right here
pretty much like the biggest chunk of
his legacy so if you guys haven't seen
any of those movies or you want to
revisit them
just want to give a list of
recommendations that way and the other
thing too i'm going to keep this really
brief
a lot of people have been you know
asking me about like
talking about black panther two
possibilities and recasting
and you know other than screen rant
doing it on the day
of which i thought was pretty messed up
and i
understand if people are starting to
have that conversation
right now right now for me personally
i'm not interested in having that i just
want to
remember his legacy and there'll come a
point in time where we'll probably talk
about it of course
uh what they might do but right now i
don't really want to do a video or talk
about
that just just let's try to put those
comments to rest
people asking about me yeah
[Music]
so
it was chadwick boseman's performance in
42 that really made us take a second
look there is
there's such an honor and dignity to the
way that he played jackie robinson
that we knew we needed for the character
of t'challa the prince of wakanda
[Music]
chadwick is an amazing actor we thought
would fit perfectly
with the mcu
hi panther what's up ladies and
gentlemen
you know he has a lot of depth it was
amazing
as an audience member to you know to
look into his eyes and see what's going
on we must
find a way to look after one another
as if we were one singer
a lot of the things about the character
are also true about chad
he's very knowledgeable he's an athlete
you know a martial artist he's had a lot
of experience
playing roles that come with a lot of
weight you know so i think he has a he
has a person he has a guy has a lot of
has a lot of weight to him i think he
brings all that that stuff to the role
not to mention that he's incredibly
incredibly gifted as an actor as a
performer and also as a storyteller in
his own right i am not
king of all people i am king of wakanda
and it is my responsibility to make sure
our people are safe
because he is so prepared as an actor
and because his character is sort of
flawless on set
it forced the other actors who had
scenes with them to kind of raise their
game
and go okay this guy's not taking
anything for granted he's really leaving
it all out there
so we have to keep up with him what
doesn't chad would bring
to the character i mean he's regal and
grounded and he brings a gravitas to it
so all of this feeds his t'challa and uh
i think he wore the crown with dignity
i was about like 17 so i've known him
for a really long time
um back in new york he did the work
obviously
you know i just think he did an
incredible job being true to the
character
i had a great time with chadwick just
warmth and camaraderie came into it of
course with a great deal of respect for
his previous work
so when i looked at him with proud eyes
you know
they were as mother and also as as
comrade my colleague and angela it is
your time
to be king
chadwick is just a powerhouse he really
is so talented every single movie he's
made there's this kind of this
internal almost nobility the black
panther has been the protector of
wakanda for generations
he's such a soulful actor and um
so professional so present really gives
so much
to the other person and he's awesome and
his presence on set
i think makes up kind of raises the
stakes a little bit for everybody
chadwick is a he's a really smart
interesting dynamic guy
and i think he was not overwhelmed but
very surprised and somewhat taken aback
by the
amount of love it ceased to become just
about
how well you have to roll in all that
stuff it's become part of our culture
just as a symbol
this welcome is one of the most amazing
things i've ever experienced
it's fun to watch just what it means to
people
at times like in my head i'll be like
well
what does this do for the world like
actually what is it
you know is it actually valuable in this
climate and i have to say
yes it actually is not because it makes
people escape
i think when done right um it gives
people hope
brings people together it means a lot
[Music]
hell yeah
[ __ ] jesus christ
oh man ah
this has been like the primary thing on
my mind these last few days
[ __ ] yeah it still doesn't feel quite
real to me
the day of it did not feel real at all
that was like two days it didn't feel
real i don't
like now it's been going like everywhere
on
social media that interview of when he
was starting to cry and talking about
the because i mentioned in the video
when we were
you know realizing he was like yeah i
was like oh my god what the hell
uh in that video dimension i was like oh
he's done interviews that just made me
cry
and i i linked it in there of
oh this is the specific one i was
talking about when you
visited uh terminally ill cancer
patients
children who were really holding out so
they could walk they wanted to
watch black panther and they looked up
to chadwick bose milan that interview
has been
circulating the internet a lot uh lately
and then um because there was a day
and when i came across that particular
interview there was a
day i think it was when we were living
together actually i was just up
super late at night and i was on this
binge fest of just chadwick bozeman
interviews
and starting again understand his craft
learning about his history with
denzel washington with his scholarship
and then
um him going on like the tonight show
and surprising the fans
i i haven't to be fully honest i haven't
been uh
like revisiting those videos over the
weekend it was just it just felt like
too
it was too rough yeah it was too rough
for me i know a lot of people have been
and that's great and i encourage that
and i probably will end up
doing that um but oh yeah engage in
whatever
way is natural for you at the time you
know
i just i remember the when i uh
i remember when okay yeah i remember
when i took olivia
to go see um actually i remember the
first time i showed her civil war she
unseen civil war
and it was that viewing experience that
was like my fourth time watching
it where we were we're like halfway
through we were like you know black man
there's like the best part of this movie
and it took me a little while to realize
that but then i remember when we saw
a black panther in the theaters her
night together and then after the movie
there was um uh this this uh
this black family like two little kids
who were there and then
everyone had left the theater but they
all stayed behind so they could take
photos in the theater and do the
wakanda forever pose and it wasn't until
that moment
where it hit me the cultural like
significance
impact of what he did with him because
like we said in the other video like
he's done so many
beautiful roles already um
you know and then i remember like when
the five bloods trailer came out we were
like you know he's more than black
panther guys
yeah but that's not to discredit the
legacy that he's left behind with black
panther
really why i'm not interested in talking
about like what are they going to do
with black rancher 2 right now
because i'm like let's just really it's
only been a few days guys
let's just really honor the and if
people want to have that conversation
fine i won't fault them um
but like looking at this right here in
the impact of
like who he was as a pr i didn't know
him but the interviews
you see with him he just he really
seemed like a genuine
passionate uh caring human being
and i've known i've met
i know some people who have had
encounters with him to say the least
and they it is nothing but like
positivity and praise of what i've heard
before he passed you know
yeah and so it's it's just i got that
like [ __ ] snot tears going
why don't we have a tissue already so uh
yeah
and um uh uh yeah this is
uh this is hard
it's weird and it's honestly kind of
weird i like
it it's it's bizarre to be so affected
when whenever there's a celebrity who
passes away and then it's bizarre to be
so affected when you're like i didn't
even know this person
yeah yet i'm so like yet it's like the
main thing
the thing is they can move you i mean
that's your painting and movies
especially with
just emotion especially for actors and
whatnot and i think it's interesting
because
when the movie came out there were big
talk about a lot of the other characters
and a lot of the other supporting cast
but
i think the more just that movie gets to
sit and and
you know take in its legacy and whatnot
you know he really is at the center of
it
and is you know yeah i don't know it's
it's hard to it's hard to process
yeah because it really does feel like
yeah a void has been left and i mean his
filmography was limited and
you know black panther is such a special
thing because i mean he played these
these you know really important really
famous figures but like
to to be in that movie that is like the
pinnacle of blockbusters to reach
everybody but also you know for the the
black community as a whole
i would imagine anyway like you said
that that that
experience you shared always uh stayed
with me and and just
i don't know i remember especially
around the time the movie came out just
yeah the
and i loved what he said about that is
like yeah what impact
is any of this having on the world and
that as a movie like say what you will
about you know like the plot or whatever
but
that really was a big cultural moment
that
brought everyone together in a very
fantastic and in a way i've never seen
before
in a way a lot of people had never seen
before and
and yeah i mean to just hear all this
outpouring over the weekend and people
sharing messages that he sent them or
people sharing experiences with him and
talking about him like he really does
it's like it's weird like rarely do you
ever think about actors
matching in real life characters that
they play but this guy
seemed like he really walked the walk
of somebody trying to bring good into
the world and to lead
and to you know speak through art and
and
everything and i from the characters
he's played from what i've
gathered from those interviews is that
he allows the story
or the positivity of whatever character
to influence his personal life
to influence who he is as a as it's just
a human being
and i i mean that's just a man as an
actor i feel like you have to have a
strong level of empathy and uh yeah it
really showed in that demonstration
and you know he was just oh dedicated
hard working talent
like the the biggest shock that i think
one of the biggest shocking things other
than of course his passing
um was to find out when he was diagnosed
yeah
and you're like wait a minute like i
don't i don't think we even really
talked about it in in the other video um
but
you like start doing the math you're
like wait so did he have it like when he
was filming civil war yeah
he definitely had him he was filming
black panther yeah and all these other
movies too
and to realize like this guy was going
through like chemotherapy
going through all these treatments and
yet he was just
knocking it out of the park you know
yeah and
uh i forget who i was reading but
somebody said like he just spent that
time living
instead of having anybody be instead of
having it
be secretly got married yeah yeah
it seems like he's took all that time
and instead of letting everyone know and
creating a paul he just lived it to the
absolute maximum
he just cemented his legacy out here and
then inspired a lot of positivity
um so yeah guys if you want to visit
some of that there are people plenty of
people out there now especially who are
putting out a bunch of
and we should probably find one to put
in the video
somewhere uh there are a lot of people
who are are in the description box for a
comment who are um
you know sharing stuff about uh places
where you contribute to help
treat cancer or helps help
fund the research because damn that's
crazy yeah [ __ ] cancer man
all right well we'll see you guys soon
watch chadwick boseman going to the chat
today guys
celebrate his legacy and the love